Oh
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen the President of
the United States and mrs. Trump
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies by the national anthem of the
United States
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Thank You Prime Minister Morrison mrs.
Morrison members of the Australian
delegation and distinguished guests
today we celebrate the long cherished
and unwavering friendship between the
United States and Australia the first
lady and I are honored to welcome you
and Jennifer to the White House and we
look forward to hosting you for a state
dinner tonight in the Rose Garden it
will be quite something the unbreakable
bond between America and Australia is
rooted in eternal ties of history
culture and tradition last year our
nation's commemorated 100 years of mate
ship since our gallant servicemembers
fought together in World War one today
we vowed to carry on the righteous
legacy of our exceptional alliance the
close relationship between our two
countries dates back to the earliest
days of the American Republic in 1792
during George Washington's first term
the American ship Philadelphia became
the first foreign trading vessel to
enter an Australian port in the coming
decades American prospectors whalers and
Merchants traveled to Australia for
opportunity and adventure they found in
your people a kindred spirit Americans
and Aussies are loyal bald independent
and very very resilient with incredible
optimism and grit our forefathers built
homes and nations in the lands of
endless beauty and possibility together
we share a common customs
common values common dreams and common
heroes in the First World War our bond
was sealed in blood at the Battle of
amel in France in the words of
Australian General John Monash the
events that took place there live
forever in the annals of our respective
nations general Monash led the operation
and began the offensive on the fourth of
July 1918 to honor the Americans under
his command on that Independence Day the
mighty Aussie and American forces
charged uphill to push the enemy from
the high ground and retake strategically
vital towns in just 93 minutes they
liberated the village and helped turn
the tide on the Western Front it went
very very quickly as general Monash
later wrote the Americans were ever
after received by the Australians as
Blood Brothers
since that day Australians and Americans
have fought together side-by-side in
every major conflict in World War two
the Aussies held the line against Rommel
for 8 harrowing months Tobruk they
sacrificed our sailors during the Battle
of Coral Sea and 75 years ago was he
pilots patrol the skies above Normandy
on d-day as we battle together to defeat
the Nazis and rescue civilization the
United States and Australia formalized
our security alliance in 1951 decades
later on September 10th 2001 right here
at the White House our nation celebrated
the fiftieth anniversary of that treaty
the next morning September 11th America
was attacked and Australia invoked the
treaties mutual defense commitment for
the
time ever in the weeks that followed as
our beloved sons and daughters deployed
to defend our freedom we took comfort in
knowing that they would have Australian
warriors right by their side
today on national prisoner-of-war
missing-in-action recognition day we
pledge to forever honor our
servicemembers captured or still missing
from battle throughout our history we
work and pray for the day when all of
our heroes return home on behalf of
every American I extend my profound
thanks to the people of Australia for
sacrificing with us and our shared
fights against the Menace of fascism
communism and radical Islamic terrorism
in the past century the friendship
between our nations has not only
withstood the test of time and war here
on earth but also led our nation's into
the Stars this year the United States
commemorated the 50th anniversary of the
Apollo 11 moon landing today we give
thanks to the nation of Australia for
its vital contributions to the
extraordinary achievement on July 20th
1969 when Neil Armstrong planted our
great American flag on the face of the
Moon the ground station broadcasting
this iconic image to the world was
Australian together our people have laid
down their lives to protect our
civilization from tyranny we have
pioneered some of the most remarkable
advances in human history and every
shared endeavor we have shown the world
what it truly means to be friends mates
and allies as we begin the next century
of our truly extraordinary partnership I
know that America and Australia will
mein for every United and defense of our
Liberty our sovereignty and our most
treasured values
thank you god bless you god bless
Australia and God bless the United
States of America thank you very much as
I just said to the president thanks mate
mr. president mrs. Trump on a guests
distinguished guests friends one and all
here in this land of liberty Thank You
mr. president and mrs. Trump for the
honor you have bestowed on my country
here today with this extraordinary
welcome Jenny and I bring with us and
our delegation the Amity the thanks and
respect of 25 million Australians for
this great country of these United
States of America 50 years ago another
Australian Prime Minister visited the
White House and he said there are too
many bonds between our two countries for
any Australian Prime Minister to feel
that he is a stranger so once again as
another Prime Minister returns as a
friend to celebrate with you mr.
president one of our oldest and dearest
friend ships it is wonderful to be here
Australians and Americans understand
each other like few other people's and
it is true that you and I have
established a very early understanding
for which I'm grateful no two peoples in
the world make better friends easier
than ours your respect for Australia mr.
president your personal encouragement
and the example afforded by your passion
for what makes America great
makes ours a very easy connection for a
century as you have recounted we have
done what true friends do stick by each
other
Ronald Reagan spoke of the truths and
traditions that define the United States
Australian share these truths and
traditions we see the world through the
same lens from the cornfields of lamelle
to the jungles of Southeast Asia and the
Pacific to the dust of Tarrant County
and now even the waters of the Straits
are for Muslim Australians and Americans
continue to stand together I'm reminded
of a story of a young American soldier
in the First World War
calling out to Moss trail Ian's soldiers
to help to attend to the wounded and an
Australian soldier replied in the
notorious blunt language of soldiers
which I will censor here but he said
sure yank I'll go we're in this thing
together mister press instance Australia
may often look he's in New York
mr. president Australia may often look
to the United States but we have never
been a country that has been prepared to
leave it to the United States we don't
that's not our way we pull our weight
like you Our Lives our Fortunes and our
sacred honor are found in our
willingness to stand for what we believe
we believe as Teddy Roosevelt declared
that national strength is found in the
ability of citizens to live out their
lives with self-restraint self mastery
common sense the power of accepting
individual responsibility and the
ability to act in conjunction with
others and with courage and resolution
we believe in the capacity of enterprise
and free markets to create wealth and to
lift all and for free and fair trade to
bring
nation's closer together we believe that
governments derive their power from the
consent of the governed and that the
ballot box and democracy is the surest
foundation for peace and security and we
believe in the rule of law and freedom
of association these beliefs spurred
this country to build a mighty canal to
stand up to fascism and militarism to
rebuild the modern world after winning a
great peace inspired the fascination
Wonder and joy of the world's children
through a little mouse who could whistle
at you who took humanity to the moon and
indeed we're going back again tore down
a wall that separated Liberty from
oppression and imagine engineered and
built a digital world that has connected
humanity in a way that we now can't
imagine living without America reminds
the world that it can be done how great
is America the world is a better place
because of this country living out its
moral purpose a world not just more
secure but more prosperous as well the
new economies of the world lifting
hundreds of millions from poverty do so
because they first saw the United States
define a century and do that first and
then invited and supported them to
follow mr. president I know that the
leaders of more powerful nations will
indeed visit this home known throughout
the world and will be welcomed as
friends but you won't find a more sure
and stedfast friend a better mate than
Australia it is a coincidence of history
that on the very day Pearl Harbor was
attacked Australia gifted a 99-year
lease to the United States to build its
embassy on our capital and 60 years
later as the presidents remarked on
September 11 another Australian Prime
Minister John Howard was here in
Washington at our embassy and he invoked
our treaty with you and pledged our
country to stand with you against the
architects of terror as we do to this
day when President Reagan welcomed
another
Prime Minister on this lawn he reminded
us liberty is not an inevitable State
and there is no law which guarantees
that once achieved it will survive
so we pledge ourselves here at this dawn
of a second century of mate ship between
our nation's to renew and modernize our
alliance for a new century to continue
to be vigilant and strong and to build
the economic strength that our world
needs that contributes to the peace and
prosperity of all whatever lies ahead in
this century I know that Australia and
the United States will go under meet it
with the same courage the same daring
the same unbreakable bond that has
defined the first century of machen mr.
president and mrs. Trump thank you again
for walking in Jenin me here and here as
true friends may God bless you may God
bless the good peoples of the
Commonwealth of Australia and these
United States of America
[Applause]
mr. president this concludes today's
ceremony
[Music]
[Music]